welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us at today's webinar targeted
cancer chemotherapy developing next-gen
antibody drug conjugates presented by
dr. jagat Reddy Gina Chula a senior vice
president research and development at
mod mad therapeutics Inc my name is dr.
Susie Belle DES and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I just want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation just simply
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
and let us know that you're having a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado let me
introduce our presenter dr. jaga thready
Jena Tula welcome dr. jeanette chilla hi
thank you all for attending my tea
seminar on lab rules that Miss curry
2019 virtual conference I'm indeed
excited to be here and thank you for the
organizers for inviting and next 30
minutes or so I'll be speaking on the
work that I've been doing past 15 20
years on developing a deeper drug
conjugates and a quick over you do what
I'm going to present introduction then
how to go about selecting the targets
and antibody for developing annual drug
conjugates then also what kind of
payloads people will be using today
conjugates and how do you go about in
through the therapeutic index and what
are the current strategies for using
algebra conjugates in the clinic and
what kind of combinations are being used
quick intro what is antipodal conjugate
it's anti podrick conjugate is a three
component molecule it's ninety body as
you can see the left side the y-shaped
cartoon the antibody and the ninety body
is linked to a payload which is shown in
the red color with a green linker so DC
component molecule complex my biological
molecule will be a developed and used
but why why one would want to use any
petrow conjugates as you can see the
left side in the Box typically people
have been using traditionally
chemotherapy where chemotherapy is toxic
and efficacious dose is very narrow and
because of the narrow therapeutic window
there will be lot of toxic effects
safety issues and concerns so however
when used as a kind of chemotherapy drug
and conjugate with an antibody antibody
act like targeted delivery and because
of that your your toxic dose will be
maximized and efficacies dose with
minimal efficacious dose one will be
using and the bindle bill archer and
product and because again your antibody
is using at the target missile where
specifically a chemotherapy drug is
delivered to the tumour site and because
of the normal tissues are being spared
and that's where the window will be
broader how does it really work
and the ADC mechanism is depicted in the
right side cartoon where a typical
antibody drug conjugate will bind to a
tumor antigen on the cell surface which
eventually internalize and then goes
through endosomes and lysosomes where
anybody is actually degraded and the
chemical halo chemical chemotherapy
pillar is released into the cytosol
depending on the mechanism of action of
the hell or where some of them are
tubulin binders some of them will be in
an averaging payload
and eventually the Sun will die and this
locomotive built up is delivered
targeted site from an IG party and if
you are seen at the progress of antibody
drug conjugate past 40 years or so some
tremendous progress especially positive
10 years and as you can see the right
side the adv ATC development over the
years since 2005 it is a pretty much try
rocketed especially past two-three years
and the the number of 86 bench in the
clinic is enormous and currently there
are about 70 IDC's in the clinical
development or on six hundred over six
and clinical trials are taking place why
there is a so much progress and
especially past decade partly because
there's a lot of improvement in the ADC
technology and human body bodies and
using such a kind of highly improved
upon engineering methods
it helped us developing next generation
adequate rock conjugate and the very
early on back there was a FDA approval
by my other chart and that sort of
encouraged the field to continued and
believe in the field and then later on
the pool of cancer and etc is further
encourage the community to continue to
develop these exciting molecules and as
you can see in the right most corner the
number of publication ninety but rock
conjugate as you can see it especially
from 2010 the significant progress in
the field that shows the promise of this
field
in addition but you know I even though
there's a lot of progress for strength
there are challenges associated with
developing a DC and we will discuss next
slides in my presentation what kind of
challenges are associated with this kind
of novel therapeutic development now
nowadays
next slide depicts what the challenges
are especially with the animatronic
as you can see the left side the tumor
cell typically when a DC point that you
muscle it gets into the cell and
internalizes and arrow releases in the
cell and then kills
this is a typical target dependent you
muscle telling the right side in a green
color the the I'd shown the toxicity in
the normal cells this could happen
through two different ways one is charge
independent toxicity where potential
antigens could be present in the normal
cells and their DC can bind designed it
in an internalized until the normal saw
and one way of one possible way you
could avoid is selecting a antigen that
you want door by anybody is make sure
that I didn't is not explain the normal
tissues and preferentially explained the
cancer tissue that's one way to overcome
that challenge
challenge each target independent
toxicity this could happen typically a
pale or conjugate to ninety body could
be falling outside the cell in the
bloodstream and that release payload
could could get into the normal cells
and kill the normal south so this is
called often target independent toxicity
and this is a potential challenge
currently in the eighties so in the
slide number six I sort of described
what are the critical factor that would
influence the ADC drug development so
they are put into four different buckets
one is the choice of tumor antigen then
selection of the antibody
selection of the linker and selection of
the ferredoxin yellow so if you look at
the NA tumor antigen one criteria the
most important criteria the abundance
you want to make sure the protein is
abundantly expressed in the tumor or
minimally expression the normal salt and
also you want to make sure for ADC a
target protein has to be internalized
when you think about antibody
antibiotic properties the most important
is affinity PK and surface charge and
hydrophobicity we will will speak some
of these in the in the following slides
and also one could use a kind of
different
platforms one can think about it and it
could be a normal AGG or a smaller
fragment a fab or a variable region and
so on so forth and also how one would
use antibody to conjugate the link tail
or a conjugation chemistry is very
critical at all when you think about
linker then often they're too broadly
categorized linkers clear bull and
non-playable linker then people recently
also use traceless linker and also the
linker stability in the past were very
critical when you think about payload
and there are many kinds of fare lots
and often people have been using
microtubule inhibitors diene and
averaging payloads and there are the
mechanism of action payloads one could
use and also critically is number of
drugs that you want to conjugate to on
your body
so again as you can see the antibody
drug conjugates a very complex molecule
it's an ID body and the a small molecule
how you could put them together to
develop a novel and therapeutic molecule
is the key here but when you think about
all these factors one has to consider so
some of these factors we'll go over in
couple spikes okay so here in the next
section we talk about how to go over to
the target of selection and antibody
selection and a typical word for ADC
development is listed or when you think
about an epod Rihan you get first thing
you think about what target cancer cell
that you want to work with again you
think about low normal and eye cancer
then you are to make sure
antibody target that is protein target
protein is expressed on the cell surface
because that's very important you can
work with an antibody ADC target should
be interested in the protein so those
are typically single TM of the team and
GP Annika products then you are ensure a
target protein internalizes
then another important target copy
number hi more is better for example her
two expressible million copies of course
not necessarily you would get target
protein at that high copy number but you
can think about card a copy number it is
about 10,000 copies per cell that's the
minimum required
they may think of an ID body you need to
have an ID body which are facts positive
which can bind cell surface and the
immunohistochemistry which you can use
the patient selection then you think
about antibody that is important for
sino cross reactivity because we use not
even pregnant primates at the safety
models in preclinical studies then you
have to think about characterizing in
winter on you and make sure that enough
xenograph human models available for
calculation if you don't have a platform
that to make human antibodies directly
you ought to think about humanizing the
mouse model Connells so the you nation
approach is very very critical when you
do all listing the new order do a rodent
and NHP speaky and shaped studies then
you do manufacturing on indian face one
plan that's a typical workflow one can
think about it
and target selection here an example
these days you have a lot of resources
bank Mattox resources available this is
one as when TCGA de ferran Cancer Genome
Atlas is a port of st. Mary's portal
where lot of data on RNA seek analysis
using normal tissues and cancer tissues
and compiled in the databases and this
is one of them if you should be looking
for a gene called Gia for a one and you
can see the one red means red dot each
red dot is the expression of GFR one in
given cancer patient but the one in the
blue and the green GFR expression in
normal tissues are normal even normal
tissue as you can see very nicely the
expression of GFR and novel tissue is
very minimal but when you think about
expression of this gene the pressed
cancer which is listed here in the left
side as you can see is a nice over
expression abundant expression the
breast cancer so when you have a target
like that and from using a current bank
Matic superb photos and it's good to
confirm in a laboratory setting a
smaller setting make sure experimental
Easton you try so again the same TCGA
that
more class analyzers you can see the
left side you can see GFR a and the
corresponding same family genes read
also over expressed in in basil her2
positive liminal en luminal P set of
breast cancers and as you can see gia
for a selectively or explained the
luminal a luminal B's type of breast
cancers over the normal and this is
further confirmed the right side in the
TaqMan analysis as you can see the blue
colored ones are the G fre and the black
one in the red you can see GFR is a
burnin you overexpress compare to read
in liminal a type of breast cancer and
some exchange in her2 positive breast
cancer but the basal only very minimal
and you can see the same was confirmed
at protein level in immunohistochemistry
analysis i hg analysis nicely again the
fre over expressed in many luminaria
patients and that was shown depicted
also they're very good correlation
between orange and protein in the figure
d and figure see if you compare the the
patient samples in the figure C which
arrows corresponds with linear
expression of RNA a low express a
protein with meaning expression of RNA a
million and fourteen and high expression
of our and acts for supporting
indicating that one can use are any
expression for an expression as a
patient selection in which a protein
comes house as you can see again when
you think about antibody selection and
what can you find your body and targets
for this is even harder than we about it
so again you are to make sure when you
make an antibody antibody binding to the
target protein both internalized inside
the cell as you can see in the figure a
the cells GFR is a muscle surface when
anybody boys cheer for a you can say
nice interrogation the yellow spots over
the time you can defecting here a nice
color well who localized in the
lysosomal compartment indicating that
93-94 t complex are internal in the
lysosome and eventually there it will be
degraded and a Sarah dissected or can be
realize there another aspect of it when
you thinking about a
signaling proteins when you're making
antibodies receptor thyroid kinases or
Ejiofor a well-known signaling Katie
enough and it's important for cheating
upon the read and G operation is very
important for normal functioning so when
you're making antibodies such as Jia for
every were to make sure it doesn't
interfere with the typical Union
interpret signaling and here in this
case 63 7 seen an idea bodies do not
have any cross functional blocking with
the Union about signaling indicating
that when you make an ADC it doesn't
interfere with regular functions of Gd
enough track signaling affair so when
you think about antibody selection for
ADC Antipa drug conjugate development so
here one way of doing it and we had many
number of antibodies to choose when you
made antibodies on EGF forever you are
the board foul-up 2590 bodies so you
want to quickly make a decision which
anybody you want to select it what we
did we we took an idea by all these
antibodies and made us mozilla a link a
pillar conjugation untested and tousle
lines one is a chica 2 9 3 saline and as
you get runnin through gia forever less
insulin as you can see the ack 2 9 3 as
no GFR a and yes you get phonology of an
opponent a expressed when you can sit on
this cell line you can see the ad sees a
group of NEC is very showed potential
put into activity on the gia for any ADC
cell line but not on a solid 2 9 3 G of
Rassilon but not on to Nerissa line the
left side when you look at the right
side the number of a DC's did not have
any person see a partial potency on this
both the salon indicating will be
interest on the left side a DC's on
further characterization we took further
and then did in view of character in
some of this a DC's tested and you can
see even though it is 677 ADC short
actually an in vitro but in we would not
see much actually and whereas 1679
showed in vitro and in vivo and
indicating you know there could be a
difference I see between Iranian we won
one of them is the peak a
pharmacokinetic properties of a given
and you
is critical for characterization so
indefinitely could be another factor too
so so these are one has to consider
before finalizing the lead molecule is
pique and affinity are to be
characterized as worked and once you
make the lead collapse selection then
the key thing is these are Mo's
monoclonal antibodies so we went head
and humanized it when we humanized it
and we had to test and compare with the
camera which are most and human-hybrid
molecules with the humanized molecule as
you can see 63 17 and is amaz monopoles
which are cameras and compared with the
humanized six to three and seven CNN and
showed that they are equal affinity and
equal efficacy in which one in vivo and
confirmed that these are little
molecules are behaving exactly the way
our original family EDC's so let's shift
again a little bit about target prior
radiation and ADC selection so till now
what we learned a typical target and ID
border conjugate smear we selected and
move on with it but when you have a
given cancer indication number of
targets available so in this case a
blood cancer and we are looking at non
and b-cell targets there number of
exciting missile targets are available
in the portfolio so how do you go about
and identifying the target that you want
to work with so in this case a excellent
paper published by genetic colleagues
back in 2009 so what they are done their
daughter brandy body is a friend of your
idea body's terrific missile targets and
then screen when they did the inhalation
staining and they found CD 79 sheet 22
are the only two targets in college very
well as you can see in the left side
very nicely the dotted pattern which are
indicative of internalization the other
ones did that in some ways Wow so
obviously I told you earlier if a
development you need to have a target
that infamous very well because you are
too dull you are to deliver the antibody
conjugated and the lysosomes also that
Taylor can barely the antibody can be
different error can be released and then
they went on to further make this
ninety-four drug conjugates tested in
vivo and to see which linker to use Cleo
ball versus non player polling so they
had the number of targets and they said
Ye in this case in in nineteen city
county one CD twenty and CD twenty two
so when they use these four targets and
tested with both clear ball in this case
STP dm1 is agreeable and Capello MCCD m1
is a non-playable link apparel or as you
can see and also I want to remind city
19 city 20 and see in front one their
non internalizing targets and whereas
city 22 is internalizing target when you
have a non internalizing target only
their worldly link appeal or worked is
the free herbal linker non-playable
linker did not work well in the case of
city 19 and cd20 and senate front you
are whereas when you have city 22 both
global and non cable link work very well
so obviously when you have a in
supplying summarizing target doesn't
matter which linker you want use the
world linker but when you are not
internalizing forget you were hard to
make sure you have three about alinka to
work with so similar scenario would CD
22 and cd1 eid only non syllable linkers
worked but where the cattle CD is 79
again same generalizing target
beautifully both linkers label non-apple
and co locked so that's why you make the
link with choice between cable was
largely over defending an insulating
property of the target so let's move on
to the carer selection in the next
section and and see what kind of payload
to choose again past ten years the the
field has actually moved on to a
different kind of varieties if you look
at the figure and in the right side you
can see there are number of ad sees in
the clinic
the tubulin agents but now past five
years or so it's start diversifying for
routine and averaging payloads such as
calcium ice in camp that these things
become ice in PPD ign's and so on so
forth so that's actually good news you
got a feather diversity more recently
than before because otherwise 50% a a
DC's earlier they're all tubulin binding
agents or using the el oued and if you
look about what kind of payload potency
you're thinking about it again there are
early on people are used
ADHD payloads methotrexate ducts or a
basin which are submaximal arranged they
did not do a good job because you don't
have enough person see then slowly the
people start moving to sort of for next
generation of historians in combination
with Hansen's which are subhanim allah
for fancy and then more recently PVD
family fiddle evangelist and family
members are yours they are a picomolar
potency so again no matter what whether
user picomolar potent payload or an
animal of some of the typical
therapeutic window has been same and
using a PPD sort of tail or the the TI
is a safety and efficacy was in the
range of 30 to minus en a microgram per
keg
when you're using a less potent pair or
such a large gardens you have one point
five to two point of make braking so
therapeutic window is pretty much
similar under the potency of the pillar
that you'll choose but it's important
what chance an indication that are you
working with and what kind of tail up
that you want work well so let's go over
some of these criteria how people have
been tired and decided which pillar to
water so here's one example of and i've
been a Peabody type of molecule where
IG and they're calling the Pendolino
there is a pin family member so here
this is a DNA cross linker payload where
is the timer is basically it's a mirror
image and what is important is the
antenna
in tenth position of this in Delano izn
moiety is very critical for DNA
cross-linking so one side this engine
position was made you mean another set
is amine group this amine group actually
will not cross the cross wing and
becomes a less potent and less cross
reactive and because of that when you
have both an amine position and the
safety has been compromised there's a
delayed toxicity observed but when you
make one of them is NH group and then
the safety is improved without
compromising the efficacy so this is one
way to improve the safety and potential
threat particular of the a disease one
can think about it you can engineer the
payload such a way so it becomes more
safer and and without compromising the
efficacy another way to think about what
kind of failure selection that you want
to think about it could be a safety
driven decision for example here paper
published back in 2015 by Genentech
colleagues what they have done they
characterize they chose as gr5 which is
not they expressed and rectal cancer but
also expressed in the colon themselves
and because of this target expressed in
the Kansas I mean almost sunset in the
colon and interest channel stem cells so
one is to be careful what kind of
payload that we won't work with so they
chose who can repair or one is to blame
inhibitor MMA another one is ions
recycling the rebate you is an MSc a con
yet linked our JD Nana wedding a lot
when the both these linker pillars were
tested on jr5 Hema models and they both
showed a similar kind of efficacy
however when they tested in the lab
safety models especially in the case of
enemies yet 180 ad see the severe tox
charge independent toxicity were
observed especially accused will I in
the intestine 50 epithelial necro
is decreased number of villi and so on
so forth is depicted in this slide 23 as
you can see however these were not seen
with Mme II kind of tell or so again
when you have a DNN averaging
irreversible inhibitors pillars these
are the things one would expect most
severe target different toxicity unlike
a mild a tubal in every test which don't
cause kind of severe attack suspicious
so therefore when efficacy is similar
between these both linked a pillow but
safety is not so you would go with mie
type of choice when you have such a kind
up for target expression liabilities in
the key stem cell population so here's
another example a better than the case
implement decision you're in the case of
AML acute myeloid leukemia cancer there
are two populations typically highly
proliferating leukemic plus then
leukemia stem cell population which are
percent and more assistant for mitotic
inhibitors so in this case you want with
me turns in our or our students they may
not work on LSE population because of
the myosin stage and for this you need
to have more Dean and Avenue fellow such
as IQ be such as IGN or PPD's and so on
so forth such Canadian and average world
will eliminate both looking stem cells
as well as the leukemic glass and this
is a very nice example recently
published by several colleagues and in
this paper blood advances but they are
shown they conjugate a PPD type of
derivative to this sealer one expressed
in target which is known to expression
LLC and leukemic class but minimally are
no expression SSE because of that it's
paired HSC but it's killed Alessi and
the blasts and eliminating the aim of
providing the benefit among patients so
then you go to the next section where
how do you go about develop next
generation a disease and what are the
from the current problem that we have
seen recently so one of the first thing
is about the antibody conjugation and
the link appeal or I think traditionally
everyone is aware and about using the
licen conjugation and system conjugation
so this lysine insisting traditional
approaches gives homogeneous population
of the IDC's which range from 0 th
species and they could be under species
when you think about system conjugation
they could be a million species when
singable eyes and foundation so
site-specific technology came up and
which helped to make the homogeneous ADC
product as through assistant engineering
by Genentech tire map technology or many
other unnatural M&S technologies the
smartest at the time in tag Supply Co
engineering and many technologies were
described in these reviews one can go
about learn more about so a quick
reminder on the site specific technology
what it can do again a couple of papers
published by John unchecked back in 2008
and 2012 and you can see very nicely
when you think about making homogeneous
versus mixed species of a disease a
site-specific ADC can provide enormous
benefit to the safety of AD antiporter
of conjugate wear support for full
improvement in the safety dose in the
cinema Louis monkeys you can see a 55.9
big perk a cup a DC match with the new
triple effect I'm by 25 neat freak' in
the left side graph is further confirmed
in multiple studies and by other sized
box
well now another important thing is
about really think about site-specific
work site to choose and this is another
paper published back in 2012 if you
think about site you know there are some
sites can provide stability and the
stability makes stable molecule
the more therapeutic in the in vivo as
you can see lights and is more
therapeutic company reach in RFC that's
partly because this light link of
parenthood attach light chain at their
side gave disability of the antipodal
conjugate that give better efficacy
without rule in the length of L or in
the plasma so this was further confirmed
by other people as well so there's
another way of doing it is you can
engineer antibodies such a way and you
can make see my antibody binding
multiple epitopes
for example this paper by MedImmune back
in 2016 what they are done they they
made by specific antibody and which
binds to different epitopes of the heart
oh and by doing that what it's doing is
this antibody can bind multiple epitopes
and that can create on the cell surface
a cluster of the clustering effect by
doing that the internalization is
triggered faster so you are actually
triggering a pasta internalization more
delivery of link up eroded into the
south
I think this is great one way where you
can create better efficacy of with it is
by specific by peritectic ADC however
one should be very cautious if their
target is expressional normal cells it
could create similar effect in the
normal cells too so therefore you've got
to make and choose whether you want to
work with that kind of approach and
other interesting approach is decreasing
her aftergut toxicity there is target
independent toxicity often ADC sever
tremendous challenges or pinocytosis so
any idea body that you give it does get
into sastra pinocytosis that's the one
of the challenge ADC field is facing
these days how do you go about it
typically mammalian cells have a highly
negatively charged so if you're naughty
body with the party
charge you can't get into the cells
without target binding so for example
this is an elegant paper published by in
Genesis last year and this a 90 body AGS
1660 yeah Annie Butler conjugate it does
get into the cells even though when
there is no target these are corneal
epithelial cells
no target expressed and it does get into
cells very good fortune see when this
tiny Podrick conjugate further modified
to have a poly lies in PL k pi it's
further improves the internalization and
killing but if you make that opposite
said Polly glutamic acid then actually
decreases the binding and installation
color so that sort of tells if you are
more positively charged on your body it
can get into the cell more if it is a
more negatively charged on your body it
can get into cells class and shown in
the right side internalization of the
honey-butter conjugate you can see the
leftmost of this right side picture is
antibody conjugated alone it's
polarization is more into the cell
implying the SS into the cells and you
can see nicely the ic50 values also
decreased when you have poly lies in
poly atomic acid compared to that
control antibody and this is further
confirmed with a decrease hydrophobicity
the penis itis could be compromised
logic faced so for example in the case
of a GS 16 c 3 a body butter conjugate
so he's very hydrophobic and you can
make it less I drove by conjugating with
pigs when you conjugate the peg and you
can see I spooky values actually much
lower compared to normal anti-drug
conjugate so as you can see however
though if you can see whether you have
the field hydrophobicity are inferior I
preserve CIF this is not compromised
well the safety is actually improved by
doing that so basically you can actually
make it more head of polluted oh I
anybody uh conjugate or you can change
the charge in this case lysine 16 to
mutated to the aspartic acid by doing so
you Mia making positively charged
surface to negatively charged surface
because namely charge don't get into the
cells by themself Rapinoe cirrhosis
unlike possibly charge and by doing
either you can make charge variants of
negative charge variance you can make
are more hydrophilic surface you can
make either way you can improve the
penis addresses you can actually
decrease the penis iris is certain
target independent penis addresses you
can decrease their by urine from the
safety of these handy border conjugates
so another ways recently I mean not
recently past few years said Amex by the
company what they use amassed antibodies
so in other words these antibodies by
themselves don't bind it because they
mast with the peptides and when it gets
into the tumor cell surface that's a
solid matrix of the tumor and people
produce clear this mask and then the
release the ID and each end binding side
up on your body and this anybody's now
can find at the tumor side so by reading
does this pairing the healthy tissue and
and only these antibodies are open for
binding in the diseased tissue and
because of that antibody drug conjugates
are safer in the normal tissues only
they are active in the in the tumor
tissue and this is a new way of looking
at it and again they just sent into the
clinic let's see how these animal drug
conjugates will work in the clinic
another way of looking at is linker
engineering so so far we learnt about
antibody engineering how to go over to
improve the therapeutic index of
dani.bora conjugate so linker
engineering is here's a paper published
by Pfizer colleagues and what they are
done
the typical crippling car they use valve
sit and this valve sit cleavable
incorrigibility issue in the mouse
plasma
so they've entered and changed around
the valve position and change the
chemical groups by doing that they
improve the stability of the linker in
the mouse plasma and of course this is
not easy
the human blossom but most of us might
just you you have challenges in the
preclinical models so by doing that they
did the either linker engineering or any
boring engineering they also change the
residues and antibody location of the
conjugation site and depending on the
side which side you use and Donnybrook
conjugates are stable in the mass plasma
or you can go ahead and change the
linker positions and undo that stability
as Rawley can achieve so you can do
either way and you could also eliminate
the premature release of the linker in
the plasma by other way is changing the
position of this p1 and p3 positions of
the linker and you're done again people
have done this paper published last year
needs a communication you can nicely see
they have replaced the basket with
glutamic acids Citroen and by doing that
they made the stable linkers in the most
plasma and again efficacy is improved
and safety is not compromised and I
think this is another way of linker
engineering so it's not a safety issue
there this paper on taxable income
stability and as well as efficacy you
can also think about improving the
linkers again is another example here
you can use their self ID bond linkers
and you can also use novel conjugation
sites to improve the disulfide bond
linkers so here in this example is what
they have done is when you have opened a
sulfide bond and then one way to protect
the decimal point is add the methyl
groups around the disulfide bond but if
you have it faceless disulfide bond
linker
anybody can protect the test will
dissolve upon linker so again you can
choose an engineering engineered site to
protect the disulfide bond in an
antibody or you could choose a methyl
group in the decimal
protect the disulfide bond either way a
combination of both can help
for example of that well into 0 phi c is
not protected is is lost in the plasma
and quickly and you can see here where
as k 1 4 9 c is highly protected in the
plasma and if you use again different
linkers your SPD BD m 4 vs Imperium
money can see SPD medium for it most
about ability impurity m1 so depending
on hard work and/or linker what kind of
conjugation side you would use you can
actually fix that kind of challenges
this is another interesting about the
radium linker that one can choose in
this case Cheryl genetics colleagues
what they are done they used a linear
peg versus branch Peck so by using a
branch peg what they have done they
decrease hydrophobicity significantly
and include the PK and improve the
efficacy and by doing so the branch peg
would help them from the therapeutic
window of 94 Okanagan again the key here
is how you put the pegleg peg spacer in
the linker where the linear wasn't
branched and by branch one I'd it
creates more hydrophilic surface on 94
drug conjugates and by doing that it
improves it makes it less clear and the
clearance rates to decrease and as well
as improve the PK as well as efficacy
Afghani but what conjugate again state
number 36 the marshana colleagues
actually went here and explained in a
different way what they are done they
use a polymer 2 conjugate multi the
conjugate number of linker payloads to
be up to 20 and typically if we used a
20 more or 20 annual link appear or Chan
or anybody will be significantly at home
bacon is very fast and however since it
is a polymer and I develop a polymer
they use here flexible molecule and
because of that that focused in
compromised adversity is compromised and
it was more a topic in the nature and
the pKa is not come but anymore again in
efficacy they improved a lot
again this is a new technology one has
to see how this can help and really what
you are seeing in the pinnacle I can
translate into the clinic and the data
will speak in and coming years I think
we learned so far how to go about
selecting target how to go over to
select 90 body out of those select the
linker how to select the payload and how
to engineer these to make a and she can
about rock or negate the question is in
feature whether the antibody drug
conjugate work as a mono therapy or not
vision therapy is upcoming and very
exciting field these days and it's there
summarized in the slide number next
slide and you can see typically these
days them number of finding bodies in
the crude antibodies one can choose and
such as or ceptin reduction of Ashton
and PD over antibody the function
blocking antibodies and then you have
this tiny border conjugate such as etc
some Casella then you think about by
specific a disease and you can think
about this including by specific
antibodies where T cells are equal to
the tumor site and they can both are you
can occur or TCR therapies one can think
about it
I think in the future remains would be
what can the combination one can choose
and how a DC's would play in a role so
there depend in the next slide for
example here a combination drugs such as
a DC's
when the ADC kills the Jamis all it can
be least number of Kimura antigen and
number of signal that can actually
activate the image should identity house
which will be primed and activated and
that would further increase the
production of the cervix T lymphocytes
which can go and kill the tumor cells so
is combination of T cell therapy and/or
TCL decoding antibodies with ABC's work
or poly wonders for example in the next
slide
people are shown in this nine
paper by Muller at all in the Science
Translational Medicine you can see then
any border conjugate tinea money used
what happened is the expression of PDL
one of the expression predominant tumour
macrophages are pd-1 RCD LF for the T
cells increase difficult ly then you can
think about using checkpoint inhibitors
such as a deep even on TPA or antibodies
or initially Labonte Boris in
combination with ADC so would that
happen improve the efficacy in the model
yes as you can see amana therapy such as
circular pore and APD one our Chilean
one partial efficacy when you combine
with either one of them you can see a
significant important figures in the
queue memorials in factors so this data
sort of speaks to it there are 23 an
antibody that kanji is currently being
studied in part by trials in ten
different checkpoint inhibitors and it's
very exciting field and I think ADC to
put our will be here to play a major
role in the combination therapy and and
and thank you all for your listening to
my talk and I'll be happy to answer any
questions
alright thank you Juna tula for that
informative presentation i'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcasts possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 2019 as a
final reminder dr. Juna Tula will follow
up with any questions you have submitted
via email that's all for now and thank
you so much for joining us we will see
you next time bye bye